there is a cruelty in what's happening
here these are people who have been
encouraged to Turkey's border with
Greece led to believe by the Turkish
government that the border to Europe is
open more than that though they are
being offered free transport in their
thousands to the frontier a bus arrived
as we filmed
this is a small village south of the
official border terminal there is no
crossing here just a river Greece and
the EU is just over there on a tannery
from a tower a Greek border guard tells
them knocked across here but he batted
another horn so hype Ahmad is from Iraq
he's been in Turkey for several years he
says but can't get asylum Europe is
where he thinks the opportunities are
next to him a 22 year old Ahmed nach a
from Gaza who is it seems broken I will
kill myself here in this place I do not
have family I have no one in this
country you what give me Murphy Murphy
BD she when no one is supporting me it's
like building okay if God will receive
me I will go to God up the bank
belongings left behind by some who did
manage to cross over night and Beyond in
the woods a group of Afghans they had
been trying to make a life in Turkey we
have left everything behind look at them
now they only have a rucksack
that's all they left everything and came
because turkish President Erdogan said
the border was open where is it open
they speak fluent Turkish but they think
it'll be better in Europe and for the
Turkish president that drive and hunger
for a better life is a political
bargaining chip at the official crossing
the cameras are now being held well back
but this is what it looks like beyond
there are all sorts here many are angry
at being duped by the Turkish and
determined to push forward into Europe
the Turkish government claims that a
hundred thousand people have crossed
into Greece in the past two days it is a
wildly exaggerated figure designed to
spook European leaders while some are
crossing over the river the border here
is secure we crossed over at a terminal
further south into Greece to see for
ourselves
the lien on this video filmed by
migrants shows them arriving on the
Greek side by the time we arrived at the
same spot there were only a few signs of
them being there the Greek police though
were here can you confirm that migrants
have been crossing okay they wouldn't be
drawn on how many had crossed but the
government says the numbers cited by the
Turkish authorities were entirely false
and misleading back in Turkey on the
river another group Iranian among them a
man who says he's a political opposition
activist with his daughter scared to be
identified and carrying papers detailing
what he says was torture in Iran he told
us he hopes it'll help him get asylum in
Europe and then with the others he
wandered on mark stone sky news on the
Greek Turkey border